il est à la fiche de creed ii où il
reprend pour la huitième fois le rôle de
rocky à 72 ans sylvester stallone est
devenu l'incarnation au cinéma de
l'éternel recommencement
thomas pied 3 chabassier dresse le
portrait d'un faux brutal et d' un vrai
temps
il s'appelle sylvester stallone et il
est américain c'est un mythe du cinéma
américain son premier cachet était de
200 dollars touchés pour un film
érotique l'étalon italien
il porte le même prénom que grosminet il
souffre d'une légère paralysie au visage
pour cause de naissance au forceps il
dit qu'il a passé près de 5000 casting
dans sa vie il trouve que donald trump
est un personnage à la charles dickens
il a réalisé la suite de la fièvre du
samedi soir
[Musique]
il a repris un rôle de louis de funès il
a tourné avec john landis
john huston allan j pakula woody allen
[Musique]
et surtout lui-même lui même est lui
même
bref il s'appelle sylvester stallone
mais tout le monde l'appelle fly avec un
rail comme dans stallone est l'auteur d'
de sa propre légende c'est quelqu'un qui
a fait en sorte de contrôler au maximum
sa filmographie n'est au cinéma dans les
années 70 on le connaît surtout pour ses
personnages dans les sagas rocky et
rambo en militaires traumatisés de la
guerre du vietnam et en héros boxster
symbole du rêve américain
les personnages de rocky et de rambo
sont des personnages qui sont toujours
un tout petit peu à côté de leurs mythes
qui sont dépassés par l'image de héros
qu'on leur a attribué à sylvester
stallone est de retour à l'occasion du
nouveau cloud ide
il redevient rocky balboa légende de la
boxe au cinéma légendes de cinéma un
rôle qui le hantent et qu'il hante
depuis plus de 40 ans à coups de coups
du droit du gauche un personnage qui
vieillit qui revit qu'on revoie qui
revient et qui nous parlent mieux
qu'aucun autre de ses rôles de lui les
talents italiens rêveurs américains
stallone pour les affiches et ce live
pour les intimes
[Musique]
tout commence par un malentendu
contrairement à l'idée souvent
véhiculées par la forme de son corps sur
les affiches stallone écrit aujourd'hui
à l'image d' arnold swarzenegger
stallone représente l'amérique du
bodybuilding pourtant titane ou n'a pas
construit ses ambitions sur son sol
corps célestes qui a six niveaux
divulgué mais qui à l'invers de
schrödinger qui lui vient du
bodybuilding s'est musclé pour être du
temps au monde l'époque
donc il n'ya pas vraiment d'obsession
viril chez lui on est d'ailleurs
personnage de rocky est un personnage
c'est féminin à sa manière et d'ailleurs
ils le jouent ils jouent presque un peu
comme john wayne et c'est à dire qu'il
ya une virilité de façade et en même
temps derrière une espèce de déhanchés
quelque chose de beaucoup plus beaucoup
plus souple et fragile qui correspond
pas aux canons de la masculinité gagner
à près de 30 ans stallone galère et
enchaîne les castings sans succès des
pactes à l'angle hi c cap au master
causey words words est recyclé et il y
en a un
alors tout d'un coup il écrit un film un
film sur le rêve américain un film sur
le dépassement de soi un film sur la
croyance et ce film c'est rocky view
pour le rôle de rocky les producteurs
voient robert redford ou james khan mais
stallone lui voit sylvester stallone et
personne d'autre et comme rocky il se
battra jusqu'au bout pour vivre son rêve
le film coûte un million de dollars en
rapporte plus d'une centaine et
s'offrent trois oscars au passage devant
monsieur bergman
[Musique]
ce qui lui a donné je pense autant de
succès c'est la mise en valeur d'une
certaine innocence qu'on trouve chez ses
personnages d'idiot justement parce que
ce sont des enfants et non pas de second
degré ils n'ont pas d'ironie il n'a
surtout aucun cynisme et donc c'est
grâce à eux qu'on va pouvoir retrouver
l'enfance de l'amérique en 1982 au beau
milieu du succès des rocky à rebours des
malentendus sur sa personne sylvester
continue d'écrire sa propre légende et
cosigne le scénario de rango l'histoire
d'un soldat qui ne s'est jamais remis de
la guerre du vietnam et le dit lui même
stallone rambo et rocky représente deux
facettes de sa personnalité
brocchi c'est son côté positif lance
temps de vie
c'est à dire que ça représente toutes
les plus belles facettes de l'humanité
la générosité alors que john rambo
c'est son instinct de mort le côté
solitaire la brutalité le besoin d'une
de tuer
[Musique]
ok alors que stallone écrit qu'il
réalise qu'il peut aussi ses icônes
rambo et rocky lui échappe et deviennent
les symboles virilisant manipulé par le
président ronald reagan à des fins de
propagande au beau milieu d'une guerre
froide
là encore c'est un malentendu
rocchi incarné le rêve américain à
savoir l'accomplissement personnel
rambaud le premier du moins portés en
lui sur lui avec lui le traumatisme de
la guerre du vietnam et regan lui n'y
voit que du pur patriotisme encore un
malentendu météo très loin d'eux portait
en lui les désirs de guerre froide de
ses dirigeants stallone comme des
personnages idéaliste de fervents
croyants
la grande différence entre stallone et
tous les autres actionnaires heroes des
années 80 c'est que c'est quelqu'un qui
est très imperméables à l'ironie
justement c'est quelqu'un qui
kim est toujours en valeur et en scène
l'innocence de ces personnages est
précisément dans rocky contre quoi se
bat rocchi le prolo innocent est très
naïf il se bat contre le cynisme de ceux
qui voudraient dénaturer le rêve
américain
ou qui sait quelqu'un qui croit qu'il
faut se battre pour l'idée que oui le
rêve américain c'est bel et bien
possible
c'est pas quelqu'un qui va se battre
pour le vivre c'est pas un battant du
tout c'est quelqu'un qui croit en des
principes
sylvester stallone a toujours su créer
des franchises sur lesquels se reposer
pour retrouver le succès rocky rambo
expendables
et chez skoda est aujourd'hui pluie dont
le deuxième épisode cartonne déjà aux
états unis et qui s'inscrit comme
l'héritage de rocky balboa
non s'il a essayé d'autres choses toute
sa carrière stallone en est toujours
revenu à son alter ego son idéal celui
qu'il considère comme son ami imaginaire
et qui a jamais le résumera lemieux
requis 300
[Musique]